the complex numbers zero u and v they
form the vertices of an equilateral
triangle in the argan diagram come on
the question even says diagram in it so
i'm going to draw an argan diagram and
i'm going to try and put an equilateral
triangle on there so for reasons of
simplicity i'm just going to draw more
or less why isn't my straight line
happening i'm just going to draw more or
less the
first quadrant here
because i don't need more quadrants to
really illustrate what i'm trying to get
at
so i know
that the three vertices of this
equilateral triangle aren't all in
random positions one of them is at the
origin so i'm going to place that 0
there
and u and v are somewhat arbitrary
in that you you envy there are no
particular qualities applied to them
independently of each other so i'm just
going to put you kind of like anywhere
let's put
this u here and now once i know where u
is i know where v has to be as well i
can kind of cheat a little bit
this is not something you can
necessarily do unless you've got a
protractor nearby but
i'm putting that about there i'm going
to make that a bit bigger you can see
what i'm trying to do here is i'm trying
to get the radius here in order to get
my equilateral triangle thing happening
so let me just put that a little uh less
obvious there okay fantastic and now
what i want to do is being that the
origin is uh one of my uh vertices and
therefore i've got this kind of length
here
from zero to u zero to v has to be the
same distance and so that's why i put
them on the i'm going to put v on the
circumference of this circle and the
question is just well where will v go
so that like where on the circumference
can i see it so that i'm going to get
not only 0 to v being the same distance
but u to v being the same distance and
i'm just eyeballing this this is only
for the you know my own
help to get a useful diagram there i
reckon that's kind of okay i hope that
you're satisfied with that um look at
that i reckon that oh it's pretty
equilateral i'm pretty happy with that
okay
so there is my diagram let's get rid of
the rest of this i don't need it um
there we go
ta-da
so now i've got my zero my u and my v
and i'm now going to try and use this
diagram to help me to show this result y
is u squared plus v squared equal to u v
now in order to do this you can
immediately see that i have to make a
choice um about what form of complex
number i'm going to use to to carry out
this operation right and this is one of
the questions i posed to you like which
form of complex number did you choose
now can i just ask you you know what
would have been clever if i did this in
the um in the poll that i you know
hostly put together now but before but
can you post in the chat for me um which
form of complex number and i'm going to
be specific here um you'll see why in a
second which form of complex number did
you use first if you changed your mind
that is totally okay but i want to know
what was your instinct where did you go
first
and then i'm going to ask you
see if we have any thoughts on why
so
why isn't the reason not wires in the
coordinate so i i've got a manual
jumping in with an early uh on
rectangular form and looks like ran
agrees uh i've got exponential mod it
looks like we've got all three okay i
still want to see a few more okay
rectangular again from sasebo um xiao
went to exponential uh who else have we
got a few people haven't written
anything yet what other forms did you go
to again i'm i'm wondering which one you
went to first which was your instinct um
anyone else okay modag for jayu thank
you
for a couple more i'm interested because
we've got we're like everywhere at the
moment um
it looks to me again i should done this
as a whole and it would have counted for
me but we've got quite a few who've gone
to exponential form which interests me
because um at least in the first
instance i also went to exponential form
and i'm about to show you why um but
you'll also see why it's partly a trick
question so
sorry but not sorry okay let me let me
see what i mean
remember i mentioned to write from the
outset that you and v are somewhat
random right they can be anywhere even
though i've drawn them here in the first
quadrant they don't have to be right so
i need to define u in in some random
terms i didn't even know how far it is
from the origin because um
it's an equilateral triangle but i don't
know how big the equilateral triangle is
so i'm going to go with uh whoopsie
daisy i'm going to go with
exponential form so r
e to the i
theta and the reason for that is because
when i think about the particular shape
that i'm interested in right this is an
equilateral triangle
once i know where u is v is no longer
random like you remember when i started
to draw this line here and then i was
like oh where am i going to position it
the position of v depends on the
position of you and i was talking about
it in terms of distance like the word
equilateral literally means equal like
length of the sides
so i've got this kind of um operation
happening right
and so that tells me for example that
this v is not just um some random you
know some other like um different r
different theta that kind of thing i
actually know it's going to say share
the same modulus as u so i can say if
i'm still in exponential form that this
is r e to the i
something else i mean clearly there's a
different argument happening here um and
you can see maybe where my reasoning is
going to go here right
if i've got r e to the i theta where is
theta in this diagram and the answer is
it's measured from the positive real
axis anti-clockwise up towards
this point right so therefore
oopsie does he i'm going to put this
theta in here you see that
now because this is an equilateral
triangle i know that this angle um or
rather all the angles in the triangle
are going to also be equal and so
because the angle sum of a triangle is
pi therefore you're getting pi on 3
everywhere right so if i say
what's the best way to do this i'll just
put the pi on 3 here
if i say this is pi on 3 then you can
infer what the angle for v is going to
be equal to or what the argument is
right because it is this theta plus this
pi on 3 right so i'm going to put that
in here i reckon i can just nestle that
in that's theta plus pi on 3 and that's
that's the argument that i'm after right
so therefore i'm going to pop that up
here theta plus pi on 3.
now i posed that question to you before
about like why would you choose one
complex uh one form of a complex number
over another and i hope you can see why
i leaned into exponential i knew i was
going to have to do some reasoning
around angles and that's just easier to
do in exponential or in trigonometric in
polar mod arg form
i went to exponential mainly because i
was lazy r it seems to have most of the
same information right modulus and
argument um so i can just write it in a
more synced form but you'll see i don't
completely escape trigonometry form at
least in this first method of the proof
that i'm going to show you okay
all right so i've got my setup right and
i wonder if this was consistent to you
if your diagram looks very similar i'm
now ready i know enough to try and prove
this result that um i'm going out here
right u squared plus v squared equals uv
i can just go ahead given the way i've
defined u and the way i've defined v i
can just compute what u squared plus v
squared is and what u v is and then
hopefully if i've done this right they
will be the same okay so i can do either
of them in any order u squared plus v
squared or uv
but given that um the complex sorry the
exponential form of a complex number is
best set up for multiplication right
rectangular form it's much easier to add
things together but exponential form
it's easier to multiply
so i'm going to start with that so here
comes my proof right
the
right hand side the right hand side is
equal to uv so let's go ahead and
evaluate that based on the way that i've
defined u and v
i'm just going to get r e to the i theta
and i'm multiplying that by r e to the i
theta plus pi on three
okay now once i've written that there's
really not too much to do to get this to
some base level like most simplified
that you can get it you can see i've got
my arguments coming sorry my moduli
coming together first so i multiply
those and then just by index laws you
can see i'm just going to have to add
those those powers those indices
together so i get
e to the i which is that's the common
factor and then what am i going to get
in the brackets what arguments are going
to add together well you've got theta
plus theta so i just get 2 theta
and then you've got that pi on 3 hanging
out the end there
and as mentioned i'm kind of done at
this point right there's no obvious way
that i can simplify this further so i'm
going to call that a day on the right
hand side and now i'm going to turn my
attention
to the left hand side okay now here
we're now considering u squared plus v
squared so it's a little more effort but
i'm still going to be able to do it
i'm going to take u and v independently
and square them right so it looks to me
like i mean here's his u right here when
you square it what happens well the
modulus gets squared so you get r
squared and when you square the
exponential part of it that's just
doubling the angle right we've seen this
before so i'm just going to get i
to theta up here in the index ta-da
there's u squared
so then i'm going to go to v squared
which is what has the same module so you
get your r squared there and then just
be careful here when you go e to the i
what again the entire angle gets doubled
so that includes the theta part of it
but it also includes the pi on three
part of it so that's going to become two
pi on
three like so
all right now you can see why i started
with the right hand side first and now
doing the left hand side left hand side
a bit of a mess
this this thing here i'm going to have
to do some sort of pulling apart in
order to try and get it to something
like this but hopefully you can see it's
already promising right for instance um
you can see right here this two theta
that i got in my original um right hand
side it's appeared here
and here so it's like oh that's
promising and also the same deal with
this uh what color am i going to choose
with this r squared right you're like oh
that's really good you can see i'm
headed in the right direction um things
are going to look good for me right
so i'm going to say equals what i'm
going to do on the next line this is one
of those places where the kind of
simplifying that you do it depends on
where you're headed to right there's so
many different ways to simplify
something
so what i notice is that what i have is
this one term up here and i've got two
here so these are separate so therefore
i'm going to try and combine things
together i'm going to combine things
that i know need to be combined in the
final result like say that r squared and
that e i to the 2 theta
the r squared e to the r 2 theta is in
fact if you have a look at this entire
first term here and then in this second
term just have a look at the first part
of it
it is in fact a common factor between
these
these two terms that i got from the u
squared and the v squared so i'm going
to pull that factor out that gives me an
r squared e to the i to theta
and then what do i get left with inside
the brackets right you've got uh let's
write like this there's just a one when
you factorize it out there and then
you've got an e to the i
two pi on three left
behind
okay so this point here i've i've
happily used um complex or sorry
exponential for the exponential form of
a complex number to do all my
manipulations so far but at this moment
i'm i'm actually kind of stuck because i
have this addition that i need to do
here and it's just not set up
exponential form is not set up to make
edition easy right all that stuff is
tucked away up in the exponents so if
you've got you know um
a common base you're good to go but but
here i don't right i mean if you're
multiplying not adding so what i'm going
to do here is i'm going to transition
out into a different form of a complex
number and that's part of what i like
about this particular question it
actually forces us into cleverly using
for particular reasons different forms
okay
so i'll write this so okay daisy i'll
write this r squared e to the i 2 theta
out the front i think it's fine to stay
put because remember that's actually my
destination essentially so it kind of
looks good
and then what i'm going to do is i'm
going to notice that inside here i can
use
if i think about just this term here
i can use mod arg form trigonometric
form to help me evaluate this thing
right because by definition or using
euler's formula e to the i theta equals
like what is it how do we define it it's
actually a cos of 2 pi on 3
plus i sine of 2 pi on 3. so i can go
ahead and i can evaluate each of those
things so i get the 1 out the front and
then what am i adding what is this going
to be equal to cos 2 pi on 3 cos starts
up here and then it goes down at pi on 2
it passes through the x axis so this is
going to be negative now and hopefully
you're you're thinking about your exact
values and you recognize that's going to
be negative a half
and then plus root three onto i because
that's
you're getting that root three um that
one two root three triangle okay
now in this form um we've kind of used
as it were we've kind of used this
trigonometric this mod arc form to get
it into now rectangular form and i
noticed people saying rectangular um in
the you know in the chat earlier and
you're like oh this is great i can
finally use this now to add these things
together so i've got some fractions i'll
really give myself a bit of space down
here i've got um
r squared e to the i2 theta hanging out
the front and then here that one
plus negative a half is just going to be
positive a half
plus root 3 on 2 i alright now at this
point i've used rectangular form to
accomplish the addition um but i kind of
want to get back to exponential form so
that i can get these two complex numbers
in here to play with each other and we
have this great advantage of having done
the right hand side and knowing where
i'm headed right do you recognize what
this complex number is um it's the uh
it's not the conjugate because that goes
vertically but it's kind of like a
horizontal not kind of like it is the
horizontal reflection of this complex
number that we had up here right so this
is cos of 2 pi on 3 if you reflect back
across the imaginary axis hopefully you
recognize that this is going to be
not e to the i 2 pi on 3 but e to the i
one
pi on three i should put that in
brackets as well which is what we
anticipated up here
so at this point i'm pretty much
finished aren't i because i can use my
index laws to put these together i get
the two theta i get the pi on three that
i wanted and that's it that is me
getting to the right hand side okay